the Clown Prince of Crime has been
around for almost eight decades and
anyone who's been around that long is
bound to do something right it might be
by accident for purely selfish reasons
or utter insanity while it's hard to
imagine here are some times that the
Joker was actually right in the DC
Comics line wide event Dark Knight's
metal DC's heroes face antagonists from
the dark multiverse in particular
they're assaulted by evil alternate
versions of Batman and perhaps the most
vicious of them all is the Batman who
laughs a black leather clad bone white
skinned Bruce Wayne with a spiked metal
headband covering his eyes the Batman
who laughs is a version of Bruce Wayne
driven mad by neurotoxin after killing
the Joker falling victim to one last
Joker trap when Batman confronts his
dark ego in dark nights metal number six
he has helped the villain overpowers him
but the Joker appears and shoots Batman
who laughs from behind together Batman
and Joker are able to defeat the darker
Bruce Wayne and Joker doesn't hold back
though his full reasoning is never
totally explained the Joker has a vested
interest in stopping the dark multiverse
Batman from the start of dark nights in
the prologue issue the casting maybe he
just didn't want the competition after
the defeat of the Batman who laughs the
character returned and a few issues of
Justice League before getting his own
miniseries alongside another alternate
reality Bruce Wayne a gun-toting grim
knight at the end of Batman who laughs
number one the Joker fools Batman into
thinking he's looking for protection
instead the Joker enters the Batcave and
shoots himself infecting Batman with his
Joker toxin as he passes out the Joker
warns the only way you'll beat him is to
become him by the end of the third issue
Batman decides the Joker's right in
spite of Alfred's passionate objections
Batman stops fighting the Joker toxin
and allows it to run its course Batman
does defeat the Batman who laughs in the
final issue but loses his battle with
the toxin he attempts to beat the now
helpless Batman who laughs to death
that's when the Joker appears pointing a
gun and his old nemesis he tells him
you're welcome and fires Joker shots
stops Batman without killing him giving
Alfred the chance to clear Bruce's
system of the toxin writer and artist
Shawn Murphy showed a different take on
the Batman mythos in the miniseries
Batman White Knight turning the Batman
Joker conflict on its head like in the
nineteen
Batman film this alternate reality Joker
was originally Jack Napier though this
one's white skin is the result of makeup
rather than a fall into a chemical VAT
white night opens with Batman capturing
Joker yet again after an attempted
robbery
Batman forces an entire bottle of pills
down the Joker's throat temporarily
curing Jack Napier of his psychosis a
saint Jack Napier is freed from Arkham
Asylum after he successfully argues that
Batman and Gotham's legal system never
tried to handle his mental illness with
treatment opting for violence he becomes
one of Gotham's most popular citizens
and eventually helps to save Gotham from
a super weapon the Joker of white knight
isn't above dark means to justify his
ends though using the Mad Hatter's
technology and clayface's unique
physiology Napier secretly takes mental
control of almost all of Gotham's
villains for what he sees as noble goals
and ultimately he transforms back into
the Joker at the end of the series but
not without saving Gotham first one of
the most well remembered Batman stories
of the 21st century is hushed by Jeph
Loeb and Jim Lee most of Dark Knight's
rogues gallery show up in the story
Riddler poison ivy killer croc Raza
cruel scarecrow Harley Quinn and
Clayface Batman even has a Throwdown
with a mind-controlled Superman and of
course the Joker's there but his role
isn't what it seems Batman number 613
ends with a gun-toting Joker crouching
over what appears to be the body of
Bruce Wayne's childhood friend Tommy
Elliott we eventually learned that Joker
didn't shoot Elliott and he isn't dead
in fact Elliott is hushed the villain of
the whole story but seeing Joker over an
apparently lifeless Tommy Elliott's is
too much for Batman
he beats Joker bloody and nearly kills
him it's only the intervention of Jim
Gordon that saves the Joker's life at
least this one time when he tells Batman
I'm innocent
he's right in 1996 his Catwoman annual
number three we visit yet another
alternate reality where officer Jack
bozer a police officer going after the
criminal duo a Batman and Catwoman gets
kicked in the face by Catwoman and falls
into a vat of chemicals transforming him
into the Joker
this world's Joker is Gotham's best cop
and he's eventually promoted to police
commissioner
Joker finds an ally in his pursuit to
Batman and Catwoman in reporter Edward
nygma new Batman and Catwoman try and
failed to kill the issue ends with the
deaths of both Batman and
woman as their son Dick Grayson betrays
them to Commissioner Joker 2019 s Batman
number 75 includes a nod to that
alternate reality tale Batman's back
breaking villain Bane has taken control
of Gotham and made the rest of the Dark
Knight's rogues gallery who's the
tenants so the comic opens with
detectives Joker and Riddler
investigating crimes and reporting to
the new Gotham police commissioner Hugo
Strange in 2017 s Lego Batman movie The
Joker has a personal reason to be at
odds with the Dark Knight early in the
film Batman asurs Joker that he has not
- in fact his arch enemy it's a harsh
breakup there is no us Batman and Joker
are not a thing I don't need you The
Joker enraged at this rejection
assembles all of Batman's rogues gallery
in one massive Lego villain army even
bothering with D listeners like kite man
the polkadot man and condiment King by
the end of the film as the city is
literally cracking in half
Batman enlists the aid of Joker and his
villainous army to help hold the city
together he's only able to convince
Joker to help by admitting to him that
yes he is Batman's one and only so if
you help me save Gotham
you'll help me save us the animated
movie Justice League crisis on two
earths depicts a version of the DC
Universe where the moral paradigm is
backwards the movie opens in an
alternate reality where instead of the
Justice League protecting the earth the
crime syndicate rules over the world
with an iron fist
instead of Superman there's the
unforgiving Ultraman instead of Batman
there's the scheming and nihilistic owl
man this Earth's cheap freedom fighter
is Lex Luthor and crisis on two earths
opens with this more heroic Lex and his
old friend the Jester this upside-down
world's Joker racing to escape the crime
syndicate to make their way to the world
of the Justice League to recruit them
for help
Lex escapes and succeeds in finding and
recruiting the Justice League but the
Jester doesn't survive the opening scene
pursued by evil alternate universe
versions of fought girl and Martian
Manhunter jester knows that neither he
nor Lex will succeed unless someone
stops their pursuit so jester makes the
ultimate sacrifice killing himself and
the two syndicate members in the process
allowing Lex to escape if you've seen
the Dark Knight's it's likely you'll
remember the interrogation scene where
Heath Ledger's Joker laughs when Batman
suggests that the Joker wants to see him
dead kill you what would I do without
you some 14 years before that movie came
out
Batman legends of the Dark Knight number
65 would begin a story called going sane
which would show that the Dark Knight
was nowhere close to being the first
time the Clown Prince of Crime would
feel that way at the end of the issue
Joker is at a loss when he believes he's
finally succeeded in killing Batman with
all of Gotham's media reporting Batman
is missing Joker's belief seems all but
confirmed in the following issue he's
renamed himself Joseph Kirk he falls in
love with a woman named Rebecca and is
close to tying the knot but eventually
the Joker's persona re-emerges and
Batman legends of the Dark Knight number
68 a flashback scene shows us what
triggered his regression as the reformed
Joker and his fiancee take a romantic
stroll in the woods Joseph takes out
what he believes is a map but is
actually a newspaper revealing the
missing Batman is alive and has
reappeared the premise of a new life
apparently can't compete with the
endless struggle between the clown and
the bat
Joe tells Rebecca he'll be right back
when
said he retreats into his old persona in
1998 Superman distant fires it isn't
clear if the story's nuclear holocaust
is caused by human error computer error
or the world's major powers getting
tired after having a weapon without
using it
whatever the case most of humanity gets
wiped out and in the immediate aftermath
one of Earth's only survivors Superman
loses his godlike powers fighting his
way through tribes of cavemen like
mutants and giant radioactive animals
kal-el eventually stumbles upon a
community of survivors including some
old allies like the Wally West flash
Wonder Woman and John Jones the Martian
Manhunter more surprisingly is that the
Joker is living among the
post-apocalyptic survivors we don't see
a lot of Batman's former nemesis but
what we do see of him is surprisingly
tame nuclear annihilation apparently for
sanity upon the Joker when we do see him
he's working hard to support the
community he's joined like building a
power generator to bring electricity
back to the survivors lives in the video
game Lego DC super villains The Joker is
one of many DC bad guys who temporarily
works on the side of the Angels when the
Justice League disappears and is
replaced with versions from an alternate
reality Lex Luthor and his Legion of
Doom soon figure out that the likes of
Ultraman power ring and Johnny quick
aren't the noble heroes they pretend to
be these new replacement heroes are once
again the crime syndicate but with the
Justice League missing in action only
classic Legion of Doom members like
Luthor Grodd Black Manta and of course
Joker can stop them we eventually
learned the crime syndicate is in
cahoots with the interstellar war Lord
Darkseid who's keeping the Justice
League captive on apocalypse eventually
the Justice League and Legion of Doom
unite to get Darkseid his elite soldiers
and the crime syndicate away from their
world presumably so they can get back to
beating each other up again as he does
from time to time the Joker helps Batman
and his allies in the 2008 story Batman
our IP which focuses on a plot by a
group called the black glove which is
intent on destroying the Caped Crusader
and company assuming that the enemy of
your enemy is your friend the black
glove recruits Joker to help out
unfortunately for the black glove
relying on the Joker's loyalty is that
don't move Joker begins betraying the
black
almost as soon as their alliance forms
killing several members of the group and
ultimately coaxing the black glove to
activate the transmitter that allows
Batman's allies to track them down
why does Joker do it a lot of it is pure
to stain the black Club prides itself on
being inspired by the Joker
while the clown sees them all is being
completely amateurish he used them as
being unworthy of his time and he
probably sees them as unworthy foes for
Batman remember in the dark nights when
one of Joker's henchmen tries to unmask
Batman the crook gets shocked by
something hidden in Batman's cowl Joker
mocks him the lackey is unworthy to even
touch Batman in the eyes of the Dark
Knight's Joker and it isn't a stretch to
assume the Joker a Batman our IP feels
similarly about the black glove there
was a brief attempt at an ongoing Joker
Solo comic series in 1975 it lasted only
nine issues but the series offers some
interesting reading
Joker's most ridiculous story comes with
its sixth issue when Joker duels the
pipe chomping Sherlock Holmes himself
and the following issue sees an
interesting conflict between Joker and
Lex Luthor and Joker number 7 Lex
invents a device meant to steal
personality traits from others he means
to use it to steal the will power from
the hero Green Lantern
but the Joker eavesdrops on his fellow
super villain he ruins Lex's plans when
he crashes into Luthor's lab and grabs
the device himself the result is that
Lex is genius is transferred to the
Joker
while Joker's and sanity forces itself
upon Lex Joker's initially find with the
switch he fakes his usual insanity
around his henchmen so they don't
suspect anything he monitors Luthor's
actions and Superman's least favorite
citizen seems to have given up trying to
take over the world in favor of
committing random crimes without caring
whether or not they succeed but Joker's
newfound genius warns him that both he
and Luthor will die from the switch if
it isn't reversed soon Joker designs a
device to reverse the personality switch
plus saving the world from it even less
stable Lex Luthor check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite
characters are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]